They don't forgive because there's nothing to forgive because I'm stuck.
I'm stuck in the oppressor group.
If I'm stuck in the oppressor group and there's no escaping it,
there can be no forgiveness if there's no repentance, right?
Like isn't that how it works so that I'm just perpetually a sinner and I'm just
going to continue to perpetuate the oppressor group.
And there's nothing that I can do.
It's an impossible, uh,
place to put yourself because you're trying to hold something.
You're trying to be open. You're trying to retain ideas and,
and also not put people down. It's tough. W what do you make of this idea?
So you hit on that, that critical theory, whatever cultural, Marxism,
whatever you want to call, the thing that it's religious in nature. One of the,
one of the facets that I'm constantly amazed by is there's no forgiveness in
this thing that basically, if you're white or you're cis-gendered,
or you're Christian, or whatever, you're privileged and thus bad,
and that really, you just have to pay penance your whole life.
You have to live on your knees, your whole life,
where most religions have some level of forgiveness, right.
You can actually atone for your sins and hopefully be a better person on the
other side. This thing doesn't have that this thing has, Oh,
well live like a slave forever in effect.
Right? Yeah. A hundred percent. So, so in,
in critical theory, you're sort of guilty, um,
you know, before proven innocent. Um, so everybody's guilty.
Um, and as James Lindsay, you know, as, as observed and in,
in his findings, um,
all of the critical theorists believe essentially that if you will, even, even,
you know, for example,
if I want to be somebody accused me of problematic Alex yesterday,
but that's the whole point,
the whole point is that I can never be truly an ally. My,
my allyship is always going to be problematic. Um, there's, you know, like,
so there's no, there's no, there's no end to it.
It just continues to be what it is. So,
uh, yeah, they, they,
they don't forgive because there's nothing to forgive because I'm stuck.
I'm stuck in the oppressor group.
If I'm stuck in the oppressor group and there's no escaping it,
there can be no forgiveness if there's no repentance, right. Like,
isn't that how it works,
so that I'm just perpetually a sinner and I'm just going to continue to
perpetuate the oppressor group. And there's nothing that I can do. Yeah.
So that's why, of course,
CA cancel culture is actually the logical conclusion of critical theory,
right?
It's the logical conclusion that to be consistent logically they have
to, uh,
be consistent in their cancel culture because they have to get rid of the
oppressor class. I hate to you. I think it's beheadings.
Is the logical conclusion. Cancel culture is just cancel.
Culture is just a stop on the way,
but we can sort of leave that just for you personally, dealing with this, um,
the idea that everything's become political. And in many ways,
I think people used to go to have religious experiences regardless of the
religion, they would go there to escape politics that,
that religion sort of offered them that, you know,
that separation from the real world to think of something timeless,
something like that, um,
to see it all seep in just for you as a leader of a community.
How's that been on you? Um,
yeah, so, so, so one of the things that I do, um,
in my role is I traveled to a number of churches. I, I don't, I'm like,
I'm not the lead pastor, um, in a, in a community,
but I go to all of the different communities. Um, and I,
I speak at a number of churches. And so what is it, what is it like? Well, um,
yeah, people are, people don't get church.
It's supposed to be a place where they like,
hear about the love of God for them. And they hear about the sacrifice that,
you know, and, and they, they re uh, remember the Lord's, um,
passion, et cetera. And so it's kind of become in some circles,
in some churches,
the gospel has totally become about current events.
Um, and I think that that's definitely problematic. Um,
you know, it, it, it, it definitely become problematic where, where, um,
in Christianity we teach essentially that everybody's a priest. In fact,
um, the Protestant reformation happened because one of, you know,
Martin Luther's 95 problems with the Catholic church was that you had to have a
priest to connect with God.
And the new Testament is replete with scriptures about the priesthood of the
believer.
And so what this necessarily means for Protestants like me is that every
believer is supposedly coming to church to be appraised.
It's what you literally do is you come to what a priest do.
They administer the Lord and they minister to others.
But like when you come to church and it's a lesson on critical theory,
you know, and there's like, there's no escape. Um,
I think that people aren't able to do their job as a Christian. Uh,
I think that, that, it's,
it's really tough to glorify God and to worship God when it's like, you're in a,
you're in a perpetual classroom, and there's just doubt and there's confusion.
And,
and I think that one of my biggest frustrations for me is that I don't think
that a lot of church leaders have their pulse on this epistemological issue.
So it's just, it's washing it.
Like pastors are good people and they love people.
And so from that good place of going, I love people. They're probably going,
we need to talk about this because this, this is a real pig. This is, this is,
this is where the rubber hits the road, but problematically, if you're not you,
don't your pulse on culture and understanding,
and the undercurrents epistemologically, you know, you're,
you're creating a lot of confusion for people.
So that's absolutely what's happening. Do you think.
Certain religious denominations and certain sex within religions are just
better at keeping some of this stuff at Bay?
So it seems to me it's not perfect, but like something like Orthodox Jews,
let's say,
have really kept this at Bay in a way that conservative or reformed Jews haven't
been able to,
or evangelicals I think have done a pretty good job at keeping it at Bay. Um,
do you think that there are like certain strengths and weaknesses from a
Protestant perspective or, uh,
or another denomination perspective that makes certain worldviews a little more
able to stand up to these?
Absolutely. So it's a focus. Um, it's a focus on,
on their purpose. Like why does, why do Orthodox Jews exist? Right.
Like they know why. Um, and I mean, look,
break down sometimes to the way that they dress, like they're in this world,
but they're not of this world, sort of this Jesus said. Um, and so I think that,
that they do a really great job, you know,
of like focusing on their community and focusing on the reasons why they
exist. Um, so there's a, there is a definitely a bounce to be.
We'll see what I look at Jesus. And it's just, once again,
this isn't a political epistemological issue, but when I look at Jesus,
I don't look at somebody who is necessarily engaged in the politics of this day.
I think that, you know, Jesus said, my kingdom is not of this world.
And so he had a little bit of a I'm in the world, but I'm not of it.
Um, does that mean that we don't engage in issues of justice? No.
Doesn't mean that we don't,
I think that marching with Martin Luther King was the right thing to do,
um, during the civil rights and, and, um, you know, uh,
I think that defeating Hitler was probably a good thing to do. Um, you know,
like, so there's, there's, I think that the church doesn't run from things,
but it's, it's finding,
it's sifting through the things that we should engage in.
How would you engage in the threshold of that?
And it's a conversation that we're having right now. And, uh, yeah,
evangelicals probably have done a really great job because evangelicals are a
bit more heady. Pentecostals are probably a bit more,
we lean a bit more experiential. Um,
and so I'm, uh, um, that's, you know, I,
I wish that Pentecostals were a bit more likely than Angelicals and, and, uh,
in that they, they sifted, they had their, you know, like Albert Mohler,
you know,
he he's the president of the Southern Baptist convention and he set out,
he sent out a letter on critical theory to all of the pastors. And, but,
Hey guys, this is what's happening. Like, but Pentecostals is a bit of the wild,
wild West and in Christianity, um, I don't know if you knew this,
but we've only been around for 120 years and we, uh,
there's 750 million of us,
and we're the fastest growing version of Christianity in the world. Like, we're,
we're going to clips, we're going to clips Catholicism in 50 years. Um,
so, um,
so our brand of Christianity in terms of filling stadiums and people singing our
songs and all this stuff, it's, uh, it's, it's a big place. And it's like,
it is the battleground for Christian expression.
And that finding that threshold of where politics are and what Christianity is
going to look like, et cetera. So Pentecostals don't, we don't have, um,
we don't have like, uh, uh, a grand Poobah, like an Albert Mohler,
or like a Jerry foul or whatever who kind of
dictates to us or will tell us, Hey guys, this is what's coming up. We're,
we're very, very much independent. So because of that,
because the nature of that, and because we're so experientials,
and because we're so kind of up on the culture,
it's a mess right now, but nobody knows what to believe,
but we know that people are hurting.
And so we're going to run towards people because we're experiential and people
are having these experiences. So we're going to love them.
But that's the rational part of our compassion seems to be a bit missing.
And we're unawares to what is really inside this Trojan horse.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about
spirituality, instead of nonstop yelling, check out our spirituality playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.